that's endured for quite a long time
everything is a medal for bravery
so my party didn't give it
a no it was a lot of fun
a lot of fun it was also a lot of
tension for me because i did
secret military research during the day
that's really cool  it was an
exciting thing
secret military research in a completely
closed area we did
n't have any handles on the doors if you
wanted to get in you either had a
key or had to make a phone call
you also had to know who you
were talking to in front of the door so you could get in
such work  i did it and we did
n't then here in the evening it was a completely
different world so secret
military research during the day and then here
such people such a colorful bunch who
had completely different ideas which i
slowly inhaled i liked a lot had a
lot of fun and kept doing
it  sweat on my
forehead
because i had to answer for myself again and again we did
n't know each other
when i was here with king
so let me tell you i liked
doing it through these people they have it
under systems that was now targeted
and that was exciting  before that I was
if not stubborn but but I
did it everyone bb alif came up with it they
were in things that were necessary let's
say that a
building commission took care of the condition
of the houses and suggested
something in which house  brought it
was always himself roof coverings when
all the roofs were broken and the cellars were
dry or they and he will also have to
watch out there were functions
which, among others, of course
I know that they
had to say help, let's go into the house the
house  book
you know she was questioned
by the relevant staff of the vp
or or the mfs who comes
to visit more often what kind of car is in
front of the door
i'd be happy to show
that we introduced holter kept
meeting in apartment made
usual  is that we met in the prater,
the bba, the
federal district committee, was involved,
but the really interesting
things were discussed outside of this
official meeting and without most of
those who were there in apartments,
but i also remember that
freter got me the first time  in his
troop beds, those standing behind him
said yes, that the seed is here from the
chairman
and we want to talk today about
the work on the hirschhof, how we
organize it and some said that
when he is here we will go,
understandably
understandable with her here  is that
some are i think run away others
will then let's not talk
so today also prevailed
and i stayed up yes it was
a bit embarrassing for me of course
encountering such rejection but that was good
and and they also
correctly encouraged yes so  with this
first resident story how to find her at the
father's and then he
offered himself of his own accord
he wanted to see you can come to a
rehearsal and then he called
the department for culture budget comics with
that he then also
got the permit and  then how
not why wasn't your father
also played a major role in the fact
that we were able to do the clock tour of the play at
kollwitzplatz
yes maybe with the
carpenters or even but the
sinner and something like that a father child and
he still does there  on the raw material with or
well now happened because we didn't pass through
the markets and when then
the people who recognize each other will get
together at some point it
's not like that anymore he doesn't think
about the fia anymore but they
survived the reunification or what
broke them  of course he likes
to work more so children
for them a full-time job so that
he does now does so many
publishing houses as well as a pension although he is
a workaholic is true i can but
the people he helped, so to speak,
they made me after the  pensioners
don't hit the walls the contaminated site or
the way you're at kollwitzplatz right now that
happens to many neither the problems
didn't have in a series with the piece
i'm gone 888 83
it's true we're more likely to do
late summer it was late for 81
that was such a  play
i think they wanted to play that in frankfurt so late
and weren't
allowed to and so we offered them to
do what you know here in the yard
come along and could do
one of the surprises and then
we came here and
had the actress  sat down down there
just read it it
was a very nasty piece you can do that
from today's point of view relatively
ridiculous but back then it was like
that my comrades
didn't understand the regional court either yes but they
were sitting in the middle of the audience even then
you have  unfortunately one of your
photographers saw them too yes that 1 1
don't you have a
little boy's play no no no not at all
when you consider that the
premiere the german
performance of jared ross play
german german germans
took place at the hirschhof that's something like that  a
blockbuster a bad play about
alcoholism the bad play yes and we
would not have met
but those were activities of civil
servants who hired the actors
who were not allowed to play it at the theater
in frankfurt or
they did the reading here
and it was like that  well attended
and there was something special there was
a photographer who was simpler and
didn't take the actors as well but the
audience and the boys were often
so cheeky that they arrested them because they suspected
one of the state security officers
got the film
out of him  and they
later developed the film and we all
have pictures full of what the presumably
Stasi photographer took that is what
I think is quite a nice piece of what
happened
the event would
not have been possible without hab because
we had a division of labor
so i always helped to organize it
so responsible with a lot of people but
so the say pushed and act
then always had to put his head out and there
was always the check to see if it was just a
screening of an
american film for example there
he had to be the closest  day to the sed
district management and why an
american film and did he then
pass the pressure on to you or not
because some had a difficult situation
he should pass the pressure on but
of course he didn't pass it on because
internally he was completely on our
side but  yes actually
lose on your side
and what they appreciate is
that he was at the institute
for nuclear safety at the time, he worked and
when there was chernobyl and in the
gdr nothing was ever officially said about it
harmless aware that from the
western television are determined  since
you knew that but unofficially
well you have to celebrate west tv west
berliners are but was far away
100 meters further measurements
were taken then for example like this and from then on
all the people who
are here also had small children
informed us about the measurement results the
they made let's say
that high pieces you find
everywhere
that's right because it was like saying
fragments you find everywhere wide
makes my father actually the the dm
arena he still stayed the bishop
piece had december had a vote
in the election was there before very  active
it is he has
the active one again in norderstedt and the parts
around again then hopes he still lives
in angola mountain roads but the parts
lying around are from the castle
or something a bit loose is a
few parts from the
city castle again  and how are they
caught there that will be
no idea as far as I know but there is
also a final part in the book they were
therefore systematically stored book values
very children sat therefore collected in a
department
dottikon that children used to be he is
my studio next door in the small
shop  been knowing that
all these dance signs parties festivals etc were
taking place then i moved on
and started with these projects and
in the last five years he has
also managed to convert me into a large
apartment in this street in the
front building it is always this one  a long way
away from the people who move to berlin
it was like that back then in the early 70s
all my friends lived in the
back building and fourth floor so then
you start to move down over the
years and after ten years
the first steps into the front building begin,
that’s the whole thing  so and
now the politburo came up with the idea of
reorienting yourself
away from the new building on the meadow towards
the city centers
because in the 20 years the city centers
had been neglected
leipzig when you were there you
didn’t even know it and at the same time you
didn’t know the whole trade  more trained
there were hardly any carpenters and
joiners these really these trades
still could also do the craft the
problem
at the same time they had
built eight slab plants from berlin alone who
had an enormous output here and
brought slabs these slabs for the triple a
la  jolla like one was manufactured industrially
and these investments in these
prefabricated buildings and they had
n't been written off yet
they were so they were 1 billion
investments now the problem was on
the meadow you can no longer build but
the slabs roll out every day and that's
why you have  said now we have to
demolish a whole mountain, for example, over a large area and then
continue to build there in this tried and tested way
so that you can get to our
street i
think because it has several advantages
for this purpose first of all it is very wide
so you could have a nice crane runway
building the wall there was yes are
on the edge yes so the great uncertainty
was yes how will the people react won
and the pilot project on
oderberger strasse was supposed
to show that yes how can you convert 1000 people
from it other apartments how
does the whole process work  and
you knew all that or
we didn’t know at the beginning of course
we didn’t know at the beginning we got that from people
who worked at the building academy
so
the rumor came about through acquaintances friends
and then they learned a
lot about building how  ready to provide
information and
support,
yes, of course, they risked being
kicked out if it became known,
but of course there was also a
mood among many, so now it
doesn't go any further, these new builds of
malzahn and so they all
took part, but  now the discovered
madness to tear it down and this whole whole
background with which it was
commissioned by the politburo we
then went to vienna
so now we had a
well-functioning
communication system here in this street through this courtyard in
other streets it wouldn't have been like that
given that you
know hundreds of people here on the street you could
just always think about the fact that
the work of the program worked
planted and watered and so you
knew each other but through the event
you can always get more people so and and because
of that you naturally have a
possibility of organizing resistance here
i think that was one of the strongest things we did
i was
involved, albeit marginally, that
we achieved that the street
would not be shot down
it starts with me from my
party or even from the state
district mayor publicis if i
knew well be informed if he
wants to demolish the area
in which i used here as
chairman
it wasn't like that at all but the boys
and girls around milling cutters today who
explored it i don't know if you were
involved what found your house  the
upper ones want the street from most
above that is also from the west
bought and exchanged land and
two more were built behind the two existing walls at the end of the street yes
and that will have prevented that so
I always say we I have to emphasize  that
i didn't even notice at first
that it was happening, but then we
moved together in a larger group to the mayor of prenzlauer
berg neckar and we got the message
that it wouldn't work like that but there is
another side to it because it was a
secret plan  the demolition it was
later made public by the holz group but of course there was never a
questioning of the people i experienced
whether they might not be in favor of the
demolition after all because you have to
imagine with the housing structure with the
housing structure this was the case with the houses that had
fallen into disrepair  houses there were of course
many people
who would have wished for something
like a thälmann park to be built here
new buildings prefabricated buildings
that is for example one in the toilet we
have yes we still have
many houses with outside toilets yes and
we were not democratic not
us  we didn't go so far as to
ask the population,
which of course would have been very difficult again,
was an originally
secret plan to remain secret to
divert the road so that such people would
come by ambush, but later there were
posters and large trucks in the
prater where the people were  who live here have been able to
experience what is supposed to happen there
it is presented quite well and precisely
yes yes to the city a whole
lot of committed people too i think
a lot of committed people there were
oppositional architects let me call them
oppositional i have a bit of a
problem because you can ask  whether there
was an opposition in the gdr there was
one but that was also a kind of
opposition there were architects jan said
you can do something completely different here
you can renovate the houses they are
almost 100 years old but there are
ways to preserve them and those  will
last another 20 years or
longer
but there was still holland co the town was
ticking and i had to
chair the meeting you can't
imagine now someone building their fence
then it's
no longer safe to go away at night when the people
in  the houses live get upset
it is maybe my event
hold my meeting just
invite the people over and remember the number
so that's a story
also had that the people who
live here built it
was planted and that when the
people  don't stick together here then
zones can arise again very quickly
or I've spoken to the
owner here about the twelve times there
were already intentions to settle here again back
here yes yes yes that was meant
more as a threat I think
because  he would like to have bought the property
in the city which i
can also understand but the
property prices but we
made sure for ten years back then that the
street is not torn down we should do it
for them when the houses are
all gone we would have
had beautiful new buildings here large public
park area prefabricated buildings standing here
bring the normal rent increases
more and more panic because you
could save these ten marks operating costs are more important than history is
rightly attached and they are
probably still coming so the
people who live here there
are some who
were probably behind  who are now going to their apartments
and we will turn on
the magic flute for the speaker you have
already read files no man I did
n’t ask for them either I’m
so keen on it I’m
ambivalent because I know if I
want to know
but I  I read a file and I have to
say that Hirschhof is astonished
and I had the chance to read it.
One of us was called Hirschhof.
Can we think that was that was
the code name or the name for the
operational process?
It was Bernd and it was on you  an awful
lot of people scheduled and and
he just appeared highly suspicious
has a thick file alone with the matter
prevails yes there was also a document issued in the municipal swimming pool
yes but there are
a few hundred pages I think it is
exciting it will be interesting even if you
listen to whoever is talking about it  gave it
to spy and exaggerate
but of course they are also very flat very
flat things banal ship for
but I am grateful to the association that he
gave me to read it  be
applied for
yes they asked me what was done
and so I thought it was quite good in want I do
n’t know how it was can’t
remember but he wanted to know what did
they say or so I
said I didn’t hear I was so
far away  or something like that looks somehow
instinctively i may have
noticed that he wants to catch up with me or
we don't know anymore but i think
there is a real danger that
with the government moving to
berlin a lot of people will come it will
also be more attractive to play games like
ours  they will reconstruct the houses
and then
we won't be able to pay the rent anymore
that seems like a real danger
we'll come back to people like
berthold rädern and the new form
of bba is now called we all stay
and bernd is there too
to mobilize with other forces that simply
maintain the structures that have grown here and
what they do for the people who live here and
there is unstoppable has how crazy about
such things
at the moment i think it's a bit of a shame
that banks has a job and there
are so few on site yes  rather,
his social
work neglects something that we have to blame ourselves for